so we're going to take a look at some
viral Tick Tock videos and since gun
control is once again well shouldn't
even be the topic of conversation so
we'll take a look at some gun control
tick tocks to see if uh maybe they make
some good arguments listen we've tried
to hear them out over on tick tock on
many different issues but we've never
really checked to see what they have to
say about guns and maybe it's really
intelligent and insightful we never know
so we'll just start at the top
my opinions are just as important as
those who were born before me I know I
am young but I know what I'm saying I'm
sick of your thoughts and I'm sick of
your praying children are being
slaughtered in numbers mothers and
fathers losing Sons and Daughters we
blame the Muslims and the Jewish instead
of the ones who actually do it this song
is an attack it's a eulogy in the memory
of those not living a proclamation to
the younger generation that doesn't
understand that the Second Amendment
isn't protection it's a death sentence
the defendants a gun and the convicted
is innocent it's ironic is isn't it a
country more loyal to Allah made in 1790
so we'll take a look at some gun control
tick tocks to see if uh maybe they make
some good arguments a war where weapons
will get the job done unless we do
something kids it's time to learn to run
it could be worse you know if you if I
had known going in if you had told me
that this is a tick tock anti-gun wrap
with a ukulele uh I would have imagined
something a little bit worse than that
[Music]
so I'll give you that like it's it's it
actually it manages to get over the bar
where I would have said it not saying
much but uh at least it Rhymes you know
at least it Rhymes so uh I'll I'll give
her that another thing too is when it
comes to the the gun control topic for
me it's a little bit different from some
of these other subjects when I see
someone like this it's a young girl who
in her mind the way to stop shootings
take away everyone's guns she has a line
in there about the country is led by a
hand with a gun it's an extremely naive
and childish and so I I can understand
if you're naive and childish why you
would think that the way to solve all
these problems is to just pick where
everyone's going that's it if you're a
young naive person it's hard for me to
even get mad at you for for believing
that because it's just a young childish
kind of view of things where you don't
understand how the world works I am much
angrier at adults who absolutely know
better or should know better there's no
excuse for you to be that naive or to
pretend to be that naive when I hear
some I don't know how old the kid is but
I hear something like 17 year old say
well if we want to stop people from
being murdered can we just take guns
away that's a terrible idea we don't
want to be a country led by a hand with
a gun well that's how every country's
LED that's every country okay violence
evil okay these things exist in the
world they always have even before guns
existed they that certainly existed
violence and evil it's always there it's
it's not ever going to go away so if you
come up with a solution that hinges on
sort of the assumption that we'll be
able to extinguish evil and violence
entirely then it's not a good solution
because any kind of gun confiscation
abolishing the Second Amendment getting
rid of the guns that solution only works
if it's accompanied by curing all evil
and violence in the world as well so if
you can get rid of all the bad guys
okay no more evil no more bad guys
nobody would wish us harm
if all of them are gone forever
um that's the only way that we could
even talk about getting rid of guns but
that's never going to happen in the not
too distant past private citizens used
to be largely that if you can imagine
private what's changed while the
internet changed think about everything
you've ever searched for watched or
tweeted on the internet now imagine all
of that data being crawled through
collected and aggregated by Third
parties into permanent public records to
keep my data private when I go online I
use expressvpn there are hundreds of
data Brokers out there whose sole
business involves buying and selling
your data they don't even have to tell
you who they're selling it to or get
your consent either one of these data
points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your physical location
but you can mask your IP address with
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection through an encrypted server
that makes it more difficult for third
parties to find me if it sounds
complicated it's not because all you
have to do is just tap one button on the
app and then you're protected so if like
me you believe that your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated VPN on the market use
mylinkexpressvpn.com Walsh YT to get
three extra months free that's exp
ressvpn.com Walsh YT
hello I am Thomas oh Tommy J back from
the dead what's up dude I'm just
visiting posterity to see how the United
States are doing well dude you can't get
much better than greatest country on
Earth wonderful so what new and improved
constitutions have you composed with the
progresses of the human mind in the past
two centuries what are you talking about
we still got the Constitution yes but
which one what do you mean which one the
Constitution you ought to know you wrote
it dude well no it was largely Madison I
was actually in France wait you're still
using the Constitution from 235 years
ago well obviously Tom is the best
document ever well only number two
behind the Bible Well only after one
takes out all that mythical nonsense
with the Miracles and the resurrection
but but hold on a minute did you not
read that I suggested redrafting a
constitution about every 19 years what
institutions must advance to keep Pace
with the times truly you must have
penned new documents with which to
govern the Second Amendment is perfect
just as it is so you have a
well-regulated militia providing
security for the free state
do what now a militia that is well
regulated what are you talking about now
guns Tom we get to have guns well no
that's not it it's provide a
well-regulated militia that shout no no
no no no dude it's about if someone
breaks into my house
what is an AR-15 oh Tom you don't know
it is a sexy weapon with one of those I
can mow down your entire well-segregated
militia with those muskets you guys had
dude check it out
it appears that my hope speaking of
being naive my hope that maybe on the
gun issue Tick-Tock would be more
thoughtful that that hope may have been
in vain perhaps so here this is just
it's just a it is a longer
uh you know maybe a little more
creatively presented version of the same
argument we've heard a million it's it's
honestly really the weakest argument we
the weakest gun control argument they're
all weak uh this idea that well people
are founding fathers the people who
drafted the Constitution uh they had no
idea that these kinds of guns would
exist and and they didn't know about
modern weaponry and if they had it would
have changed everything I mean that
argument it doesn't even get off the
ground the people who make the argument
are constantly claiming constitutional
rights that our founding fathers
certainly never would have ever
conceived of inconceivable our founding
fathers did enshrine and codify into law
our right to own firearms now it's true
they didn't have a crystal ball they
couldn't see into the future to see what
exactly a firearm would look like in the
year 2023. although these were
intelligent men and so they knew that
technology progresses I don't think
they'd be shocked by that I don't think
they'd be shocked by the concept right
and yet they enshrined that right anyway
so that probably tells us everything we
need to know this weapon is your life
what the left is claiming is that the
the development of those arms now
somehow overrides the basic principle
which is absurd meanwhile they're trying
to invent basic principles and put them
into the minds of the founding fathers
even though they certainly never
imagined that we hear the claim that uh
the left believes the right to an
abortion is constitutional so it's a
basic human right constitutional right
really that's so you think that's what
is that what Thomas Jefferson had in
mind no let's let's do the same skit
with Thomas Jefferson finding out in the
future they would determine that somehow
buried in there in the Bill of Rights is
is a mother's right to kill her child so
could we play out that exact same
scenario where we're explaining to
Thomas Jefferson oh yeah you know that
right that you gave mothers to kill
their children you know that right no no
you meant to put that that's in there
isn't it trans rights okay
let's explain trans rights to Thomas
Jefferson let's see how he feels about
that oh you know the right uh no it's
the right of um of men to pretend to be
women and to have uh their fantasies
affirmed by Society you know that right
you know it's the fundamental human
right that you enshrined
constitutionally for men to disrobe in
women's locker rooms then you mean you
put that in there didn't you absolutely
not now in all those cases they damn
well know that our founding fathers
would have would have cried out in
horror at the notion that uh that these
would ever be considered rights much
less constitutional rights but there
they're willing to say well it doesn't
matter who cares what they thought
anyway they're a bunch of holes they
don't know what they're talking about
but on this when it comes to gun rights
they say well they never intended that
to begin with we must get back to the
original intentions it was really
supposed to just be malicious nothing
else carrying muskets that's all they
that's all they meant let me get this
straight you're not gonna wear a mask in
a pandemic because God will protect you
okay
then why do you need a gun thank you for
coming to my TED Talk
get that off the screen I can't deal
with the smug look
I can't deal with the smug look after
they say the dumbest that you've ever
heard it's one thing to hear the dump
but then the smug like they're so
impressed with themselves that they just
made this point that's incredibly stupid
well you say a mass that God will
protect you nobody said that who and by
the way so this was a this was a video
from a couple years ago that woman it's
almost certain that if we check in with
her now she's not wearing a mask so of
course the anti-mask people they were
right about everything we were right
about everything but back in the time
when this was something we had to argue
about nobody was saying oh I don't wear
a mask because God will protect me from
the viruses it's not what anyone said
that's not what anyone said we're all
aware that sicknesses exist and we can
still get them and uh this is part of
this Fallen World like we all knew that
our point about the mask was always that
they're useless that they're pointless
that you have no right to require us to
wear them uh that you know the the the
the risks and involved in going out in
public and potentially picking up a
sickness we always knew about that
that's always existed it's worth the
risk to just live as normal human beings
being able to see people's faces and
show our faces in public and live as
normal people it's worth the risk of
like catching a cold those were our
arguments not what she said it's as much
as I could tolerate made it through
almost 15 minutes
again